it's been a difficult few weeks for the
Chicago Police Department after the
revelations of more police brutality and
an apparent department-wide cover-up
Mayor Rahm Emanuel apologized no citizen
is a second-class citizen in the city of
Chicago
his words might be too little too late
Chicago has more police involved
shootings than any city in the US and
the city has paid out five hundred
million dollars in settlements and legal
fees since 2004 it's pretty bad in
Chicago but the thing is it's been that
way for a long time
corruption within the department dates
back to the 1920s when Chicago was
synonymous with gangsters and crooked
cops who couldn't get a handle on
misconduct within their department in
1968 after Martin Luther King jr. was
assassinated riots broke out in Chicago
the city's mayor Richard J Daley ordered
police to shoot to kill protesters later
that year when the Democratic National
Convention was held in Chicago
riots again erupted this time between
anti-war protesters and more than 11,000
police officers more than 200 people
were injured over five days a study
released later that year claimed the
riots were mainly the police's fault and
condemn the fact that no officers were
prosecuted the next year Chicago police
shot and killed black panther Fred
Hampton while he slept then allegedly
covered up the crime scene then came one
of the biggest scars on the Chicago PD
between the 1970s and early 90s one
Chicago detective named Jon Burge was
accused of torturing up to 200 mostly
black men while they were in police
custody in order to score a confession
victims say Burge and his midnight crew
subjected them to fake executions
suffocation burning and electric shocks
with cattle prods in 2008 Burge was
indicted the people in police custody
that were abused and tortured were
suspected of awful crimes but that is no
excuse torture and abuse and no place
the Chicago police station this year the
city officially apologized and set up a
reparations fund but because of the
statute of limitations Burge was never
officially charged with torture instead
he was convicted of lying in a civil
case
spent less than four years in prison and
still receives a pension fast-forward to
2015 when another Chicago PD bombshell
was dropped
journalists uncovered that the police
were running an off-the-books holding
facility in an old Sears building
basically a black site the investigation
found that police used the site known as
home and Square to essentially disappear
suspects for hours or days at a time
while interrogating them of the 7,000
people that are known to have been
brought in only 68 were allowed access
to a lawyer or to call their families
and the suspects held were
overwhelmingly black and mostly detained
for drug possession the Chicago PD for
its part says it abides by all rules
when interrogating people at home in
square an official investigation is
slated for this month the decades of
secrets and abuse runs deep in the last
four years 97% of almost 30,000 citizen
complaints against officers have
resulted in no punishment whistleblowers
within the police department say there's
a culture of fear where anyone who
points the finger at corruption is
punished or ostracized
so with decades of police abuse and
corruption kenna mayor's apology really
fix anything
and what will